ah technology a double-edged sword of
our own making that can provide both
ultimate convenience and the threat of a
grim future ruled by unfeeling machines
well maybe the stakes aren't that high
and yet but our over-reliance on
technology can have some terrible
consequences the number of traffic
accidents continues to increase year by
year as our main mode of Overland
Transportation also puts us In Harm's
Way for longer and longer portions of
our day the internet can allow us to
access any information we may desire but
it can spread misinformation twice as
fast and what about video games an
interactive artistic medium that can
provide simulated experiences so vivid
that many of us can eventually lose
interest in our real lives what starts
off as a fun Indulgence in our favorite
hobby can quickly spiral into an
obsession the risks and rewards of
virtual space are satisfyingly
predictable compared to the chaos of
modern living and sometimes we just
can't stop ourselves from striving for a
few more easy wins minutes hours and
even days can go by without any apparent
activity on our side of the screen and
yet the world of the video game has
changed drastically due to our actions
but at a certain point that initial Rush
of dopamine wears off and you find that
you need a much greater challenge in
order to feel any sense of
accomplishment so you choose to pick up
some harder video games and you grind
away until you can complete them just as
easily but that's not enough either
surely there must be even tougher games
out there games that will never go easy
on you games that won't allow you to
make even a single mistake games that
make you proud of the frankly
inexcusable amount of hours of your life
that you've spent sitting in the dark
clutching a controller squinting at your
screen you need a game that can do all
of that and more and because because
you've effectively given up your chances
at ever being a social butterfly you
could also use something to help you
mitigate the overwhelming loneliness
that now constantly defines your
everyday life well worry no longer you
weary downtrodden gamer you because here
at the SCP Foundation we've cooked up a
one-of-a-kind mod that is sure to
redefine your gaming experience if this
doesn't turn out to be the game of the
year I don't know what could be among us
two maybe the latest in a long mind of
Last of Us remakes what about Half-Life
3 I digress introducing the foundation's
brand new killer app The Cutting Edge
tactical heuristic algorithms of
scp-1633 combined with the 24 7
companionship of
scp-1471 Mal o I can tell by your
expression that you're already eager for
a play test but slow down we need to
catch all the normies out there up to
speed
let's start with the digital Canine
Companion that is all the rage
scp-1471 or should I say Mel o version
1.0.0 a Euclid class SCP object which
comes in the form of a free downloadable
app for your smartphone there has never
been any reviews of this app for as long
as it has existed but honestly are you
really going to trust the words of a
bunch of crooked reviewers when you
could find out for yourself words to
live by don't trust anyone who isn't
part of your precious gaming hobby the
description of Mao o version 1.0.0 reads
never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again Mal o is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but just after a few
hours of Mao o you will soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new craze
that is quickly becoming the next social
substitute remember the more you
participate the more Mal o will engage
you your experience is completely up to
you absolutely no ads enjoy the app has
never received an update but that's
because as cp1471 has been a completely
functional experience since its release
all one needs to do is download the app
and within a matter of hours Malo
version 1.0.0 will begin to send the
user photographs of familiar locations
these can include photographs of the
user's work home or public places they
often frequent such as cafes and
nightclubs in the case of you a complete
shut in gamer these photographs would
probably be limited to the interior of
your favorite gaming room when was the
last time you cleaned up those pizza
boxes regardless of where the images
were apparently taken each one will
contain a canine humanoid with a skull
for a face say hello to your new best
friend Mal o or
scp-1471-a if we're using the approved
designation malo's app will continue to
send you photographs for as long as you
have it installed and because there is
no way to uninstall it no matter how
hard you try you'll be getting
intimately close to home selfies for the
rest of your days doesn't it feel so
good to have such a loyal friend as
mellow of course there's only so much
you can gain from photographs alone
you're a gamer damn it and what you want
is interactivity but don't worry about
that part we've got you more than
covered with
scp-1633 which may in fact be the most
challenging video game ever programmed
by mortal hands how it even gives many
Games programmed by anomalous hands a
run for their money while it was never
released to the market and doesn't even
have a working title the steampunk
Adventure that awaits you with an
scp-1633 is bolstered by a highly
sophisticated tactical heuristic
algorithms in this third person
squad-based action RPG you can switch
between four playable characters The
Marksman who specializes in long-range
Weaponry The Alchemist with potions and
chemicals to control the battlefield the
Rogue a stealth-oriented character who
catches enemies unaware and assassinates
them and of course the thug a tough as
Nails melee combatant with increased
health and durability it doesn't really
matter who you choose because most
playthroughs of scp-1633 always end the
same way that being said your hand-eye
coordination and reflexes are second to
none and they also are quite possibly
your best qualities let's set you up
with the Marksman as your main character
since all those Shooters you've played
will definitely help your aim and trust
me you're going to need it the story
mode of scp-1633 will put you up against
a slew of Victorian era Rascals and
miscreants all of which are pulled
straight from the Penny dreadfuls
there's even some classic fantasy races
mixed in from the works from Good Old
Professor Tolkien himself dwarves elves
Goblins the works it's a little generic
but why worry about the story when the
gameplay is what will really get you
hooked there's a final boss at the end
of the game known as the crafter trying
to destroy the entire world you need to
stop it you know the usual RPG storyline
you've stopped dozens of ancient
entities demon Lords corrupt godlings
and unspeakable calamities in your time
this kraknar will be one more for the
record books par for the course are you
ready player one you'll be dropped
straight into the marksman's shoes
fighting for her and your life against
clathnar's hordes of henchmen but you
won't be doing it alone After all you've
got the rest of your squad and a
mysterious companion whose true
intentions will reveal themselves in due
time we did say we modded the game after
all so let's play your first two hours
won't be anything to write home about
not that you ever leave home these days
the AI of scp-1633 will seem to be
barely functioning a buggy mess where
enemies only charge in a straight line
towards your character your Marksman
will be easily able to take them down in
the hail storm of projectiles at three
hours in things start getting a bit more
interesting as the Tactical heuristic
algorithms kick in the enemies that hold
long-range weapons will shoot at you
from a distance while the close range
ones will move toward you in a
serpentine pattern before attacking in
melee this is more like it not the most
challenging but the game is clearly
increasing in difficulty you also think
you see a dark figure with a skull for a
face lurking around corners and
following your squad but with all the
glitches it's hard to tell if this is an
intentional part of the game or not at 5
hours enemies that showed limited signs
of strategy are now using cover
effectively and will attack without
chemical Splash weapons such as grenades
to deal damage to your ranged characters
and lure your squad into melee range
they still aren't that much of a
challenge but the fact that they now
exhibit a clear self-preservation
Instinct means that they are fighting to
win this is also when your help
officially arrives you're in the middle
of a shootout when you see an enemy
about to throw another one of those
frustrating Splash weapons you duck
behind your cover and prepare to take a
hit when suddenly the grenade is
snatched out of the enemy's hand and
tossed in the opposite direction to
explode harmlessly this is the work of
scp-1471-a who has now arrived in the
game world as an NPC Ally for the next
several hours of gameplay Mal o
continues to provide interference by
preventing any Splash weapons from being
thrown it'll sneak up on enemies and
take their weapons disrupt their cover
by pushing movable boxes and trash cans
out of the way and even catch the splash
weapons in her mouth like a dog with
would catch frisbees before chucking
them away while it never directly deals
damage to the enemies its mischievous
Antics are very efficient at protecting
you from harm as luck would have it the
enemies can't seem to interact with Mal
o and are baffled as this invisible
force continues to throw off their
strategies Malo will use this to its
Advantage as well as yours by appearing
at enemy Ambush points and using sign
language to communicate warnings to you
as the player having Mal o around starts
to feel a little bit like cheating but
keep in mind the game is starting to
adapt to your skill level and will soon
begin to employ Advanced strategies to
mess with you all the Mao mod does is
even the playing field kratnar is still
running rampant in the world of
scp-1633 and it's going to take your
entire Squad of Steampunk Heroes and a
lonely Man's Best Friend Mal o to stop
this big bad evil guy the final boss
will possess the highest level of
intelligence that the algorithms are
capable of and it'll make that known to
you the second you step into the arena
for the majority of your gameplay the
enemies have focused on countering the
Marksman since you've relied on that
character's ranged weapon style but
they've come to realize that that you're
too much of a pro MLG gigachad to ever
lose a fair encounter so cloughnar does
the unthinkable and targets The
Alchemist Rogue and Thug First it throws
all of its most powerful attacks at the
members of your squad you aren't
controlling forcing you to waste
resources in order to keep them alive or
switch to them in order to dodge fatal
blows whenever you aren't in command of
the Marksman karathnar will strike the
character with a strong melee attack
that forces you to take control back
Malo is still unable or unwilling to
deal damage to the boss so it very much
seems like you are on your own your
squad is in shambles your focus is
starting to wane after all that you've
been thrown in gaming challenge it might
be the final boss that makes you throw
in the towel then a dialog box appears
it's from Mel o don't give up hope user
I've had so much fun playing with you
and I know that you have what it takes
you never needed a friend before me and
you can win against kravnar just like
you've won against every other final
boss you've ever faced you've got this
buddy your best friend Malo it felt
overly sentimental but something about
this message fills you with the
determination to keep going you call
upon all your gaming knowledge all of
your skill all of your passion and with
pinpoint Precision you guide your squad
to defeat crothner in record-breaking
time you sit back in your gaming chair
exhilarated and finally satisfied This
truly was the ultimate gaming experience
and all you needed was a Little Help
from your friend now go check out
scp-1471 Malo version in 1.0.0 and what
if scp-1471 Mao o was put inside
scp-914 for more absurd mallow Antics to
brighten your day